just got to put yourself in the position
of one of these Global Elite assuming
that those are your three objectives and
you look at the world around you and you
say okay what do we want to promote
through the media I'm about to be
assassinated after this show too by the
way if our goal is global Marxism where
we're just calling the shots you know
how do we get how do we get from a point
A to point B using the entertainment
business or let's just say influencing I
don't want to go so far to say they
control everything you know but they
influence right and they influence the
mainstream media so how do we influence
these groups that have massive influence
on Society at large to help us have a
higher probability going back to that of
achieving these objectives if our
objective is to have kind of a global
Society that's this tops down type of
approach and in that world you would
want the people making the decisions
that lean more towards
you know however you want to say
whatever your term communities aren't
these um and this is the point that I
was going to kind of make earlier if to
become a member of the global Elite you
got to make some money and you're going
to make that money through capitalism
right like you said a great quote that
you said is if you want to have a bigger
piece of the pie well grow the pie I'd
be you you said that on kiyosaki's uh
Rich Dad Radio channel so
um
who like who is actually at these Davos
because I know billionaires are there
you know Ray dalio famously went there
and said you know cash is trash if right
before the pandemic it caught a lot of
heat from that obviously major uh
players at different countries are there
but a lot of them are capitalists though
so how do they justify being a
capitalist but also and even living in a
capitalist Society but then sort of
sounds like they're kind of indoctrinate
this Marxist Global agenda is that am I
am I interpreting that wrong well I
wouldn't call them capitalists I'd call
them fascists and and I'm not saying
that in terms of uh you know being a
racist or anything like that but more in
economic fascist where they like that
private public partnership is how they
always describe it so if you're a
monopolist let's say if you're uh you
know let's say benioff was is the CEO of
uh Salesforce
um you know he's just like a disciple of
Klaus so it through his worldview you
know why should I not buddy up with this
guy where it gives me a huge huge
Competitive Edge you know in a world
where politics are very very important
where these Global governments have
massive control
and power over the purse strings you
know why if I'm a corporate CEO why
should I not want to get in bed with
these people because it gives me a
massive massive advantage and it helps
me build a moat around my business to
eliminate any of the competition you
know so it it does give them a massive
Competitive Edge so that's that's
capitalism versus what you're describing
as crony capitalism yeah so when I talk
about capitalism you'll notice I I very
rarely ever use that term all by itself
you're like saying free market Capital
that's right I know that's right that's
right explain the difference free market
capitalism or when you have a free
market where no one has a Competitive
Edge no one is being bailed out right uh
if you it's it's the ultimate
meritocracy what you're talking about if
you don't provide a good or a service to
Consumers that they're willing to pay
for then you're going bust and what's
going to happen is the people that
behave more prudently or the p people
that by choice of the consumer that
they're willing to spend their money
with they're going to take over the
assets of the people who go bankrupt and
Yo's Milton Friedman said free market
capitalism is a profit and loss system
but loss is even more important than the
profit
see and so what we're doing now is we're
propping up all I mean go back to the
GFC you know the global financial crisis
that we had in 2008 we came in and we
bailed out all these Banks we propped
them up no no let them fail it's
Jupiter's creative destruction and yes
we would have had a depression for a
year or two but then the market would
have picked itself back up the capital
and the resources would have been
allocated to those who are more prudent
of course and the economy would have
been far more fundamentally sound today
but see so what they're trying to do is
gain favor with these politicians to
make sure that if we do have a recession
or a depression you know they're going
to get all the handouts they're going to
get the bailouts that's right so like
the airline companies right I mean
that's exactly sure so like the um
exactly Patia I'm sure
not a fan no um well he famously is
something you probably are going to
agree with though George
um is that when 2020 hit and all the
airlines got bailouts he said let them
fail yeah because sort of the premise
Pat talks about this sort of the premise
about capitalism is the freedom to
succeed
but also the freedom to fail yeah like
hey you're [ __ ] up buddy yeah see you
later yeah I totally agree with the
rules so you agree with him on that one
a lot of the airline companies prior to
2020 and 2018 2019 you know after the
the Trump tax cuts what they do with all
their the extra additional Capital they
did stock BuyBacks right so they didn't
have to do that they could have uh you
know kept cash on deck or what have you
so what do you agree with on that what
do you disagree with chamoth on that
well I agree they should have gone bust
absolutely and and let's take it a step
further then what happens so then all
the the airlines come in with these
mandates which were just crazy and why
were they doing that well put yourself
in the position of a CEO you know that
the government yeah now can effectively
shut down the entire global economy they
can just say you know what we're going
to lock you in a cage for a year and
you're gonna go ahead and do it
so that was unprecedented right talking
about 2020. right so if you're a CEO of
an airline and you know your business
can be shut off just instantly
and you just got bailed out so now
you're beholden to whatever
Administration is in power so if they
tell you you're going to do a mandate or
you're going to do mask mandates or
whatever they tell you basically you're
going to do because you know that they
could turn off the economy at any moment
create a recession due to fear whether
it's Justified or not and you know that
you could need another bailout
so it gives the government this insane
control very similar to the government
that you're talking about in Germany in
the 1930s to our yes the private sector
technically owned the businesses and
owned the shares but they were heavily
heavily influenced by the government and
we're seeing that same thing play out in
the United States and I think the
globally their objective is to have that
not just at a state or country level but
at a global level where there is private
ownership but they're the Puppeteer in
the game crony capital I like what
you're saying here George I don't just
call it capitalism you call it free
market capitalism so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]